ce dimanche 31 janvier conflent recevait
vitry à l'occasion du 6e tour de la
coupe de france dans une rencontre qui
se disputait à huis clos une atmosphère
particulière qui n'a pas bouleversé les
joueurs locaux
surmotivés les conflanais rate une
magnifique occasion début de match
quelques minutes plus tard conflent
prend les devants grâce à cette superbe
frappe en lucarne avant de réaliser le
break 2 à 0 avant la 36e minute
vitry tentera de réagir mais rate un
penalty juste avant la pause quand on
regarde de loin elle est parfaite parce
qu'on mène 2-0 mais il y avait beaucoup
de choses encore à réguler et les
traverses à la paire un penalty
peut-être arrêter aussi on peut le voir
aussi de ce côté donc parce qu'on avait
la baraka avec nous peut-être aussi mais
on a tout fait pour
on a un surnom qu'on appelle si les
dexter on tue direct est là aujourd'hui
on avait des attaques en raison des
énormes au churn en mettant la seconde
période est moins riche en occasions les
jours de conflans défendent face aux
offensives de vitry les yvelinois
concert finalement le score victoire 2 à
0 direction le 7e tour de la compétition
pré côtoient après cette belle victoire
là c'était dur là c'était dur ça faisait
longtemps n'avaient par le fait de match
officiel mais bon là on a réussi à tenir
les 90 minutes et voilà on a une belle
qualification et on va retravailler
cette semaine franchement aujourd'hui un
arbre et mot qui fait on savait qu'ils
sont allés gagner on allait rester toute
la semaine ensemble et qu'on allait se
revoir donc ces tests et c'était
vraiment l'objectif numéro 1 de se
revoir et d'avoir une vie sociale comme
le coach le dit souvent
et du coup j'ai envie de dire que c'est
réussi et on est content
au prochain tour le club de conflans
recevra saint brice l'équipe du val
d'oise évolue également régionales une
la rencontre se disputera ce dimanche 7
février toujours à huis clos